[Musique]
vous connaissez et ça paris paris paris
paris pour les parisiens ce ne sont pas
des monuments mais des boulevards des
avenues que l'on arpente se rendre à son
travail pour faire des courses pour
flâner quand on a le teint à certaines
heures le nombre de piétons mètre carré
devient soudain presqu'au pressent ce
phénomène chaque jour renouvelée
paradoxalement attire sur les trottoirs
parisiens des personnages pittoresques
qui trouve dans cette concentration même
l'occasion d'exercer leur petit commerce
en vend de tout sur niveau bas ont vendu
7 du 4 du neuf
choisissez bien elysées pour moi svp on
vend de la coquetterie partie l'aude
plume de cet lavande qui pousse sur le
dos d âne de l'uniforme et du sourire
des promesses
n'attendez pas après demain pour être
millionnaire
[Musique]
des fleurs et de la pitié de la santé à
l'américaine
en vain on achète on débourse on empoche
les petites sommes pour aujourd'hui
des sandwichs en attendant demain
regardez moi vite
j'arpente les champs elysées je suis
noir j'ai un bel uniforme donc je suis
si heureux shushan boy ambulants jeudi
en une fleur promesses foulard pitié
tirage et lavande
à paris on fait aussi commerce devant un
peu de vent passe dans les tuyaux d'une
carte postale
une jolie barbe d'époque un peu de
douceur de vivre dans un orgue de
barbarie
je n'ai pas peur des conventions je ne
crains pas le mauvais goût je suis dans
le temps des pierres je suis le rouge à
lèvres des poids paille
il y avait une fois un joueur d'orgue de
marc large autour de lui paris a
construit un pont et ainsi est née une
fille d au commencement était la musique
sur le premier al
[Musique]
monsieur leader voilà parce que bien
longtemps quand vous jouez une langue de
barbarie
oui il ya très longtemps combien de
temps à peu près
ça paie
plus de
plus de 50 20 ans ou par là oui ça se
perd dans la nuit des temps oui parce
que jugement un peu partout ne peut pas
toujours rester sur la plaine les armes
là vous avez passé plusieurs années pas
mal d'années sur le pont-des-arts
l'agent si vous attendez connu
oui c'est l'inconnu réforme massive et
aux états que depuis quelques temps on
vous voit plus souvent déjà là on ne
voit plus parce que un agent m'a dit
qu'il fallait faire public ne fallait
pas rester là parce que ça gêne à la
circulation
non ça ne gênait pas du tout mais il a
dit il faut pu rester sur le pont parce
que il ya eu des trous bleus mans avec
des gens qui écrivaient par terre il y
avait il y avait des gens qui venaient
jouer
est ce que vous en pensez de ça ben moi
moi moi j'en pense que que ça m'a fait
mon tort que je n'ai pu j'ai pu pouvoir
rester sur le pont des arts
est ce que vous considérez comme un
musicien la vision considère comme un
musicien vous faites de la musique mais
vous n'avez pas besoin d'une technique
comme un violoniste annoncé par la même
chose c'est pas nous comme un
accordéoniste chorale généralement c'est
pas la même chose
mais évidemment vous êtes un musicien
puisque vous faites de la musique
précise le fait de la musique de l'or et
les gens qui vous donne sur le
pont-des-arts vous donne de l'argent
parce qu'ils aiment votre musique à il
aime écouter cette musique là quand ils
écoutaient ça il disait que c'était bien
sûr le pont des arts ça paie ses impôts
un bon succès et que c'était joli à voir
sur le pont
avec cet ordre csu présence à présenter
l'ancien temps c'était bon levier paris
ça représente elle prépare hills ce
n'était donc pas une mendicité pur
annonce était pas ils demandent is it et
ça c'est pas une démence itella de
mendicité c'est quand vous tentez la
casquette que ça vous n'avez jamais
tendu la main un jamais tendu la main
j'ai joué mon âge je jouais je m'amusais
les gens les gens mais ils écoutaient il
donnait il partait il écoutait la
musique était content au revoir monsieur
victor
quand vous ne serez plus là votre place
sur votre banc favori sera éternellement
prête à vous accueillir et les passants
toujours entendront votre petite musique
si modeste et si nécessaire
les halles de paris
là aussi la concentration humaine est
remarquable aux terrasses des cafés et
restaurants on voit surgir des musiciens
ambulants camelot effrontée poète parmi
les paysans
je ne suis pas parisien mais j'adore
paris je suis un petite fille à l'accent
du midi
je fais le camelot pour gagner ma vie
quand j'en ai envie hein
eh ben j'ai créé des chansons je sui mex
de long oui chez magdelon gp le câblo
pour gagner ma vie
le câble ou à la sauvette le câblo à la
sauvette qui vont sur les boulevards
quand les gens font leurs emplettes
hiller dit au hasard approché messieurs
mesdames voici des nouveautés c'est une
vente ' réclame vous serez satisfaits
c'est un tout petit métier un petit
métier de paris que l'on aime et que
l'on chérit les plus profonds de soleure
est la voix du vietnam eux qui vous
savez qui vous dites est un petit métier
de
paris
[Musique]
voilà mesdames messieurs si vous
débordez vos petits jouets des petits
jouets qui me permet de gagner ma vie je
dois vous commencez à vous présenter la
toupie qui se retourne sur la queue on a
attrapé par la queue et hop là ronald
chammah et tout ça pour 2 francs
maintenant je veux présenter mes dents
mais c'est la dernière nouveauté
je vais vous prévu lancer vous présenter
monsieur maurice herzog
pascale meurisse 9 le vainqueur de la 9e
journée et voilà
alors en avant pour l'ascension 1
allez-y grimpé de subir un grain 2 1 2 1
2 1 2 1 2 1 2
[Musique]
à
la de gracieuses colombes accentue la
sensation d'art
le charmant spectacle détourne
l'attention de la musique pour le cas où
le musicien ne serait pas un virtuose
accompli
[Musique]
e
mais
oh
[Musique]
et
ravie et un mécénat s'il vous plaît
faites au compteur et n'oubliez pas de
points côtoiera bonheur mauvais selon
deux pour le force de voleurs n'hésitez
pas prenez votre corps de voleurs
et bercy d'avant
[Musique]
bonjour madame la concierge peut-on
adoucir les moeurs dans votre cour si
accueillante
bien sûr l'écho parisienne sont des
caisses de résonance ménagers entre les
murs pour chanteur et violoniste
[Musique]
oh
où
pis
[Musique]
et bien voilà
ah oui
oui
ton vote par ici
en accompagnement je crois qu'on va
falloir commencer je suis charmé
voilà messieurs dames écoutez bien
prochain nous lançons monsieur le
comédien vient la danse la pitié 6 me en
aller mon fils m'a dit avec moi y'a rien
faire il doit de non à l'état
[Musique]
à toi
ah bon
la vie
mua
[Applaudissements]
une chanson est planté leur plusieurs
personnes du groupe
c'est la chanson d'edith piaf non rien
de rien
[Musique]
non
rien de rien
[Musique]
non
je ne regrette rien
une millona
acorn mater et nigériens
tout sommet mien
[Musique]
non
rien de rien
un peu je ne me rendrais d'aia
mais c'est perret
allez y
oubliée
je me fous du passé
m
qu'aurait pensé élite piaf de cet
hommage un peu encombrant
la note juste se fait rare peut-on
remarqué mais le coeur populaire est
toujours valide de clichy passant aux
ternes
cet homme si convenable dalle lure est
aussi un musicien ambulant mais tournant
résolument le dos aux orgues de barbarie
du temps passé il a conscience de vivre
au siècle de l'électronique et fait
descendre jusque sur le macadam les
découvertes de la science moderne un
cabas en plastique dissimule un
gigantesque orchestre qui démarre au
bouton en avant pour le concerto
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
ah ah ah ah
un peu
oui l'instrument roi du trottoir reste
l'accordé
[Musique]
m
ban
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur albert vous considérez vous
comme un musicien l'existence puisque je
suis tombé aveugle à 15 ans j'ai été
éduqué à s'amender où j'ai appris le
piano
tu m'as donné beaucoup de goût à cette
musique est à majorité alors je me suis
mis à l'accordéon et depuis ce temps là
j'ai toujours fait les balles et gac
depuis que je suis tombé malade que je
me suis mis admettre dans la rue
est-ce que vous choisissez votre
quartier pour jouer monde en dansant que
vous avez joué au plus près de chez nous
comme je meurs pas très loin de torcy je
prends mes 3 1 à torcé la nordiste en
moi et je descends à saint lazare et
puis je veux ou tour je reste pas
longtemps
[Musique]
albert huber et le nom de cet homme
aveugle qui parle si simplement de ce
voyage de torcy à saint lazare
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
demandait pas le ballon le long je
demande pas l'aumône on jeu je sue de
l'accordéon et la fouettent pour te mon
accordéon et pillé on peut m'apporter
quelque chose le refuse ça s'est fini
c'est donc une sorte de salaire bien
écoutez je fais ce que je peux vous
faire plaisir aux gens
en essayant de jouer le mieux possible
et les gens vous remercie à des chansons
toujours gentil avec moi
et est ce que est ce que les agents sont
gentils aussi avec vous bien les agents
ont forcément que voulez vous on leur
leur conseil n'est ce pas ils nous font
circuler
bien souvent car c'est pas autorisé vous
n'avez pas d'autorisation de reina sur
la voie non non non ça s'est défendu
alors qu'est ce qui se passe quand un
agent vient il vous prie circulez vous
aller plus loin partir c'est défendu et
qu'elle offrit qu'ils noueraient depuis
bien souvent bien souvent c'est à dire
nous on prend très souvent mais on nous
emmène quand même au commissariat et
hambourg lâche rapidement bien ça dépend
il ya des flacons reste 3h 4h 5h
ça dépend les jusqu'ici jce tu poses
aller trop souvent vous jouez donc à la
sauvette sur le taux de oui c'est à la
sauvette
est-ce que vous formulez une souhait que
cette situation change
ah je voudrais bien que ça change je
voudrais bien qu'on ait l'autorisation
de jouer évidemment de temps en temps
moi je vais vous penserez souvent joué
le samedi et le dimanche
parce que ma santé ne me permet pas de
bisous et plus souvent
est ce que je peux vous poser une
question indiscrète mais est ce que vous
arrivez à vivre en juin seulement le
samedi et dimanche ah non allons je peux
pas je peux pas vivre en seront les
samedis et dimanches parce que je touche
un petit quelque chose d des aveugles
quand même ceux touchant petit quelque
chose
et puis malgré tout vous avez à mon âge
maintenant on n'est pas trop nous
penserons déficit nous savons se
contente d'un peu
[Musique]
tant de peine pour un si maigre résultat
tant de joie de faire de la musique pour
des oreilles si peu attentive cela
suppose une respectable vocation non
monsieur victor monsieur albert nous le
savons vous ne tentez pas la casquette
grâce à vous la musique la naïve la plus
savante la sincère la vraie autant
qu'une autre fait encore recette
sur les boulevards des grandes cités
[Musique]
à
peu m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
le
mais
m
[Musique]